what are the factors of a number how do
we find out if a number is a factor of
another is for a factor of 24 to know if
4 is a factor of 24 we simply divide 24
by 4 and find out if the remainder is 0
or not is the remainder 0 here if we
divide 24 by 4 we get the quotient as 6
and the remainder as 0 so what does this
imply after the division if the
remainder equals 0 it tells us that the
divisor is a factor of the dividend
since the remainder is 0 here we say
that 4 is a factor of 24 it also means
that 24 is divisible by 4 or you can say
that 24 goes exactly into 4 in short the
factor of a number is an exact divisor
of that number now I would like you to
answer the next question is 5 a factor
of 24 to know the answer let's try
dividing 24 by 5 5 times 4 is 20 and 24
minus 20 gives us 4 we get the quotient
as 4 and the remainder as fall since the
remainder is not 0 we can say that 5 is
not a factor of 24 that's how we find
out if the number is a factor of another
or not how else can we understand this
the fact that 4 is a factor of 24 tells
us that 24 can be divided into 4 equal
parts and the fact that 5 is not a
factor of 24 tells us that 24 cannot be
divided into five equal parts a factor
is nothing but an exact divisor of a
number now let me ask you another
interesting question how will you find
all the factors of 24 take a moment and
think about this
we cannot try dividing 24 by all numbers
and see if we get the remainder as 0 in
each case that would be
so yes there is a better way in which we
can find the factors of a number we see
that in the next session